كان رائد الفضاء الأوروبي
ماتياس مورير يختتم سبع ساعات من
السير في الفضاء خارج
محطة الفضاء الدولية عندما لاحظ
تسرب المياه إلى خوذته ، وأعتقد أنه
يجب علينا تسريع الخطوات
لإخراجهم من البدلة
هنا لقد أخرجوه ولكن الحادث وقع في
كانت مسيرة هذا العام مشابهة بشكل مخيف
لما حدث لرائد فضاء إيطالي
في عام 2013. أشعر بالكثير من الماء على
الجزء الخلفي من رأسي ، كان الماء من
أنابيب التبريد داخل بدلة
الفضاء لوكا بارميتانو يتسرب إلى خوذته
وكاد يغرق بسبب
دقيقتان ، ربما هناك أكثر
من دقيقتين ، لقد جربت ما يشبه
أن تكون سمكة ذهبية في حوض السمك
من وجهة نظر السمكة الذهبية ، إنه
سيناريو كابوس وفقًا
لرائد الفضاء المخضرم ورائد فضاء ناسا السابق
غاريت ريسمان الذي أصبح
أول مهندس بدلة فضاء في Spacex
، ومن الواضح أنك إذا ملأت الخوذة
فلا يمكنك التنفس
ولا يمكنك خلع الخوذة لذا
فأنت في  مكان سيء سيء
وأصبح خطيرًا للغاية ، أوقفت ناسا الآن
جميع عمليات السير في الفضاء في
محطة الفضاء الدولية حتى أعيدت بدلة ماتياس
الفضائية المعيبة إلى الأرض في وقت لاحق من
هذا الشهر لإجراء فحص ، ولكن حتى إذا
تم إصلاح المشكلة الأساسية هي
أن هذه البدلات الفضائية أو emu هي
عقود  قديم ولم يتبق الكثير